[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je devais rencontrer le seul d otto dix
huit mois alors que depuis anthropologue
ça consiste simplement à aller à la
rencontre de l'autre et à l'observer ces
premiers moments sont précieux pour le
chercheur sans le savoir il noue des
liens avec ce qu'il pourra un jour
peut-être appeler ses amis alors votre
fils a disparu
et vous dites qu'il est chez les autos
pis les autos pis dont vous savez oui
non j'ai pas de nouvelles de lui depuis
plusieurs semaines je n'ai pas vu
fabrice qui l'accueille depuis au moins
trente minutes mais je sais où il est il
est dans la pièce d'à côté donc fabrice
n'a pas disparu vous comprenez le
malheureux candidat puisque je m'en fous
nous allons monter une petite expression
j'ai un petit quelque chose ça ne me
fait pas plus plaisir qu'elle vous les
gars
vous rappelle qu'on est sur une scène de
crime donc s'il vous plaît d'une touché
à rien bon voilà un touché c'est du
mercure c'est le tapis sont des
chercheurs d'or ou des fabricants
thermomètre l'anthropologue n'est pas un
homme comme les autres
voilà pourquoi la folie les guette comme
à la recherche de ce jeune homme pas du
tout les gueules cassées chrysler
n'avait pas eu quelque 1 400 dépassa
vous êtes un vrai fardeau rasta y est je
veux dire vous êtes un poids pour les
chiffres comme une sorte de boulet
comptez-vous seul patron choisir sa
cellule un irlandais écoutez moi bien si
je veux me torcher avec ça je me torche
je fais des petites boules avec je
prends un petit bâton je me le fou dans
l'oreille je me la récurent est ce que
vous m'avez compris je comprends surtout
vous êtes obsédé par vaux horrifie
[Applaudissements]